Git user media, is also a bridge to
audio input. This means it's relatively straightforward to
input a voice memo recorder, or voice processing,
through the web Audio API. Now, the Web Audio
API is a pretty huge subject, so we
won't really be going into it in this course.
For more on the Web Audio API, check
out HTML5 rocks. Or webaudiodemos.outspot.com. I did briefly want
to mention though while we're on the
topic of audio, mobile devices typically prevent
audio from auto playing. Audio elements need
to start playing in response to user input,
like the full screen call we talked about earlier. On Safari, web audio is also
the same. You have to create the audio context in response to an input event.